obviously when it jumps
to the youtube clip i just need to
maximize screen
you
oh
we've had apologies from councillor
purdy um
and also councillor tate uh maybe a
little bit late or probably likely to
join the
meeting shortly thank you does anybody
have any declarations of interest
another being received here okay
i can three the minutes of the last
meeting
um i've got one issue there um
the election of the um
deputy chair is down as councillor
whitehead
but he's been put down as being a member
of the derbyshire dales
you apologize we will of course make
amends on that one
okay though thank you um any other
issues on
minutes of the mid last meeting i'll go
through a page at a time if you like so
page one
page two
page three
page four and that's it
everybody okay with the minutes can
somebody move that they be
accepted and approved as a full and true
record
good job thank you second
emma's content good okay thank you
um so the next item item for is the
quarterly service report please nikki
[Music]
hello everybody um welcome
uh you should have all received a copy
of the entire city quarterly
service report and be familiar with the
format by now
um i'll provide a brief overview
overview and some opportunity to ask
any questions sorry chad just before we
begin just to remind members that
a uh revised version of the text was
sent out today so that's the version
uh that will be presented thank you chad
can you check everybody's muted i don't
think i am actually
yes i think that's why everyone's muted
and talked about
something to say um and if members could
remain on camera
okay thank you okay thank you
um so the report covers the last six
months april to september
i think we didn't have the uh the one
after the quarterly one
um quarter one so it covers the
six months uh regarding number of
incidents and service requests
that the joint ict service received
it remained high throughout both quarter
one and quarter two
with july being the highest combined
total of incidents and service requests
being raised over the past 12 months
there has been on average an additional
230 incidents and service requests being
raised per month in comparison to last
year's
average so it sort of shows the increase
um that we're having to deal with at the
moment
increase is mainly due to the additional
quests due to coronavirus lockdown and
the associated changes that have gone
on to facilitate remote working
and we're continuing to work through
those
outstanding calls um the total number of
outstanding calls has remained
consistently high over the
past six months and it's due to
continue the high numbers of calls since
the covid outbreak
it's likely to take some time to reduce
the outstanding call lists
to the pre-covered levels that we and we
would expect
project work and or future slas possibly
to be impacted by this additional work
that we need to backlog that we need to
get get rid of
um regarding civil service level
agreements
um as anticipated there were some
breaches to the sla
seen during quarter one due to the
increased workloads due to coronavirus
and the business continuity activities
um however it was minimized to only two
breaches
and the first one in april which was for
bowls over was only just
less than one percent we missed the sla
by one percent
um however in may derby shidells didn't
meet the sla
by 9.2 after may
um there were no breaches of the sla
between june
and september so no breaches during
quarter two
and sla for first time fixers were not
breached during either quarter
outages um during the six months there
was
just the one priority one outage in
august this was due to a fault with our
internet service provider
during this outage the open vpn
connections provided some resilience
and the outgoing internet connections
were diverted through alternative
connections to maintain
business continuity
as we move on to project resources and
the percentage time spent on projects
was on average over the 35
target during quarter one um but
percentage time spent on projects during
quarter to quarter two was lower than
normal
as resources would dive to resolving
outstanding
calls the report has a summary of the
major projects highlighted and the
appendix 2 will provide more details
regards the budget currently there's
some on
overspend with the employee costs side
of the budget
this is due to additional restructure
costs which have been taken this year
and we are confident that this should be
accounted for by underspends due to
delays in recruiting to vacant posts
and some of the training budget that's
not required due to the funding we got
from the lga
transport budget wasn't spent as you'd
expect there isn't as much travel going
on due to kovid 19
however we haven't had the ict fund
charges yet they always come in at the
end of the year
we got services that is under spent at
the moment that's really to do with
bills get charged yearly at different
times of the year
and also that some internal ictv charges
have not yet been completed
the income um we've got a little bit
less income than expected this time of
year but that's further into
normal recharges that are to be
completed
regarding the cost savings plan um
i think we've mentioned this before
we're currently investigating moving
northeast telephony to the sip
away from the isdn lines that they've
got that will
provide some savings and
there's been delay delays in that at the
moment due to the uh
prioritization of resource due to kovid
19 activities um we're currently still
in
in the process of um installing a new
joint internet connection which will
deliver
cost savings of just under 3 000 per
year and the internet
improved internet bandwidth although
this will not be
until september next year and there will
be some overlap
whilst we have the two links up to up at
the same time
regarding security breaches as nothing
major to report
and we had an ipad that was stolen and
we had some application vulnerabilities
which we
which we've been able to patch
regarding service development we've
appointed a new administration assistant
to the post
um after the lady retired and
we've recruited the recruitment of the
technology officer
post is currently in progress and should
be completed by the end of this
month and the recruitment of the senior
application development of supposed is
currently on hold
um has anybody else anybody got any
questions further questions or queries
about the report uh councillor hughes
you've got your hand up
dave dave yeah thank you chair um
yes there's just really um there's a
one comment and that is uh a few months
ago i asked whether we could have a
short briefing note on on the individual
projects that were going ahead because
it's
quite it would be quite difficult from
what is in
in the project status register to
brief anybody else for us to brief
anybody else on
the impact of any changes in the status
uh
because we don't i mean i i really don't
know what each of the systems
is doing uh and what its outcome is is
intended to be
like i can't i couldn't for example
brief my group members or full council
on
the impact of say one of the red alerts
rag ratings um in the in the
in the um in the report
um and i was wondering whether it was
possible therefore
to do a um just an overview
a paragraph on each one of those on each
of the systems that's being developed
for the paragraph on each of the ones in
the report
that would give us a more a fuller
understanding
of what that system does and the impact
of any therefore the impact of any
delay in that system what we have added
is a column to the report although i
know it's very
small when it comes to you um to try and
explain a little bit
more about what the project is
for or why we why we're doing the
project
um i'm not sure if you've seen those or
if you prefer me to just go through
a bit of an overview of it that's that's
perfectly fine
i just don't want to um go into too much
detail to
if it's not relevant to everybody but
i'm happy to
to go through the report if you prefer
the project register
no i don't particularly i wouldn't want
to go through it at the meeting because
as you say it wouldn't be relevant
to to most people but
it's it's i think when that when a
project has started it would be very
useful to have a
sort of project document created that
was available to committee members
yes um which outlines what was uh what
it's intended to do and what its output
is
and the main constituent parts which are
then referenced
would be referenced in this report
on those lines i think is what i'm i'm
sure i'd like to suggest
that is perfectly fine we do every time
when we put a project before we put a
project on the project register
we have a project brief which goes
through the scope
and the costs etc and what the purpose
of the projects is
um which will highlight all those things
some of that
might not be relevant but
um maybe that's something that the
members need to
need to be more visible or we could have
a cut down version that
that you see so that you can understand
why the projects are going ahead and
what the priorities etc are yeah
that's exactly what i would hope to see
i think isn't that we
do need to be able to report back to our
to our full council meetings on
on various things yeah i mean well i can
we can look into that um look into how
we could how we could
um send that out to the relevant members
um so you're fully aware of what's
what's going on
thank you thank you very much yeah no
problem thank you
yeah thanks david i've got no other
hands up all the no
further questions oh i can't see them on
here
right counselor taking councillor
whitehead okay council take them please
yes thank you very much um you may have
covered this because a little bit late
to the meeting
but we discussed a previous meeting
about um
security issues regarding uh
the it systems and we were going to be
sending out a
a test email to everybody within the
council has that been covered already or
no it's not um the fishing exercise
that's just such quite
yeah it was put on hold during um covid
because we were so busy with all the
things at the time
um i did send out some emails i think
you may have
seen the fishing emails to try and do a
bit of a training in the
interim um until we get that that
that fishing exercise completed um
yeah i don't know if you saw that there
was a link to youtube which was to give
an explanation of phishing and trying to
prevent people from
from clicking links etc so yeah it is on
um it is on a high priority but we've
we've got some other issues that we've
had to deal with obviously during covert
time
okay thank you yes councillor whitehead
yeah thanks thanks chris um yeah just to
support
um kevin on that one i mean i've
personally been affected
um by some phishing emails so it's it's
and
it's in the news that it's on it's some
increase so that's certainly something
that we
we need to step up uh and consider
and again just to support david um i
think that approach uh what nicholas
just described is the best approach of
of issuing out um the the details
and the descriptions and if councils
want to dig into the details it gives
them
the ability to do so nicola on the um on
the i'm just going to pull up my screen
but on the um the status report where we
got the rag
um there is a project description or
update
i think if they if if if we could have a
few more words not not war and peace but
just a couple of sentences uh and making
those
updates meaningful um that that would be
our go-to place
to to get um a brief update in terms of
where we are
if that makes sense that's fine i know
sometimes
we use it as a technical sort of
document as well so obviously yeah
the the guys do put things in that uh
perhaps don't make sense to everybody if
you if you're not
on the project so completely yeah
appreciate that we could we can we can
work on it
and me and kristen are working on on
better more efficient ways that we can
produce things we are looking at kanbans
and
and um different ways of of producing
these reports which make more sense to
everybody and are more useful
um so so yeah bear with us but we can we
can certainly do that
yeah thanks nikki i can't see anybody
else alan have you got something on your
screen
speakers
alan you muted i certainly am sure to
apologize no i can't see anyone else
okay well thank you very much for that
nikki so we'll move on to
item five which is just a verbal report
we haven't got any papers on this have
we
um and the question is why microsoft
stroke office
you're now about to receive a
presentation rather than actually any
reports and such
okay thank you yeah um
i'll just share the screen for you joe's
just going to
share the presentation for me hopefully
hopefully there's a little uh youtube
clip in the middle which
i just hope we'll make
i'm sure okay that's okay
can you see that now yes that's
brilliant
okay okay yeah it's a presentation i
think when we uh
if we yeah that's fine just presentation
i think you'd asked about to see
sort of what microsoft 365 office 365
um could do um
so i'll just go through it there is a
youtube clip that joe's going to try and
um put on the screen for you to see and
hopefully sort of it will just help you
try and understand what
collaboration what what teams could do
to help you collaborate so
hopefully it comes across with this but
um yeah if you could go to the next
slide please joe
thank you so just to recap um while we
were looking at microsoft or office 365
um if you remember back up back again
please
if you remember back in november's
committee meeting i did a presentation
advising the committee that we will need
to move to office 365 before april 23
as the version of microsoft office we're
currently licensed for will no longer be
supported by microsoft
and also to acknowledge that there will
be significant additional yearly revenue
cost to the office 365 licensing and
which will need to be accounted for in
annual budgets
and also that there'll be a significant
amount of resources
required for the migration and adoption
of office 365 across the councils
not only for the joint ict department
but also for members
and staff to learn and adapt to new ways
of working
um you're asked to see what sort of
additional benefits officers
365 could provide to the to the council
and
since november a lot has changed due to
covid
um with additional requirements for
staff to be able to work effectively and
safely
remotely and for councillors to
represent the wards
whilst maintaining social distancing the
requirement for microsoft 365 has become
even more important
in helping the council perform
effectively
remotely and in a more agile way can we
go to
slide 3 please
thanks joe okay um so before we go any
further i just want to explain that
microsoft renamed office 365 to
microsoft 365.
and this is because it incorporates more
than just the office suites and it's got
the familiar office applications such as
word excel
outlook but it also incorporates a whole
range of different products as you can
see in the infographic
circle here i'm trying going to try and
keep it brief
i'm going to focus on a small section of
the microsoft products
and provide you a few examples of how
they could be used to help
improve how the council communicates and
work more effectively and
efficiently i'm not only going to
demonstrate how it could improve
collaboration and communications for
yourself as members
but some ideas and how officers and
staff could utilize new ways of working
along with additional security and
resilience it could bring
if we go to slide four please joe
okay so outlook exchange online um
office 365 allows us to put emails in
the cloud
um you'll receive a large mailbox up to
100 gigabit
um no more annoying space limitations
however
there's also considerations with this on
the backup requirements the data
retention policies etc to be considered
um it does have some um on the e3
license that we will
buy it will provide some basic methods
to try and prevent the
loss of data for example detecting data
that may have bank account details
or sensitive information and preventing
it being copied or forwarded
however this again will need
configuration and policies to be put in
place
to be effective um there will be some
increase for resilience but this will
also require
increased security so having exchange in
the cloud
could provide greater resilience and
improve business continuity in the event
that the on-site premises were lost or
disconnected
however this also increases the security
threat as controlling access to the data
in the cloud is more challenging
so exchange online it won't necessarily
give you all the staff any notable or
amazing improvements to how you work but
it is necessary to move
um to more effectively utilize the other
microsoft 365 products
can we move to the next slide please
thank you
so yeah microsoft teams um
this from my point of view and hopefully
you'll agree is probably the most
exciting product
which will most likely provide the tools
to help the council collaborate more
effectively and efficiently
um joe if you could just play the
video i've got a short video it's good
to see of finn jones on youtube
and it's really to demonstrate at a very
simple level of how collaboration tool
like teams compared to traditional email
could improve how we operate and
communicate
okay just bear with me
let's keep this simple you need to make
a decision
but need the input from four team so you
can draft an email
and send it to the team person number
one
replies to all so it is question number
two but three and
who four they should have the same
legislation as well person number five
replies to everyone
you can remember the feedback and send a
synopsis back out to everyone
we also receive emails from persons
number one and two asking why number
five was included in on the discussion
you reply back to them that
although not ideal it'll be okay person
number five also forwarded the email to
person number six who
at this time also replied to all but
didn't get the last email
so to include her you forward her the
last email and
see everyone else just to let them know
the person on the discussion
too
ask for one small change you agree make
the change
and email everyone again for an
agreement everyone emails you
and they agree
by the end of this madness 61 emails
have been sent to make one decision that
certainly is not
collaboration at its finest how can we
avoid this in the future
instead of sending an email you ask a
question in a collaborative environment
everyone responds and reads each other's
responses
and suggests that person number five and
sex be invited which you do
day two at their two bits and everyone
is on the same page
you make the final decision person
number six
add the change you revise and everyone
buys up
think about how much time your team
saved by using these positive space
multiply that by the number of in-depth
conversations you have in a day
and you can see the savings plus
which always makes your team happy now
richardson
thanks joe
if we can go back to the presentation
that'd be great
there you go thank you and if we can
move on to the next slide
i'm not sure how well that came across
but the link will be in the
um presentation that we send out to you
if you want to look at it again
um yeah some of you will already already
have used teams
um for this type of collaboration or
maybe just as a video conferencing tool
um to give you an example that maybe
some of you can relate to
um of how teams could be used would
maybe for
say a scrutiny committee or some other
sort of board where you're having to
make a decision
and somewhere where there's a mix of
staff and perhaps members
possibly some outside consultants
included such as the police or members
of the public
or other local authorities involved
in teams a team can be set up and
created with all these people involved
to discuss what it is you want to
discuss or scrutinize
instead of checking several emails you
have one area to read through and
comment
as you saw in the screen as you wish
with the addition of the sharepoint and
onedrive set up you will be able to
share photos links
videos documents and spreadsheets all
very easy to find in one place
easy to search in on that
that scrutiny channel or that decision
channel
meetings could be scheduled and you
could quickly join together in a video
or an audio conference with these
members of this team
and so that you could discuss the work
further
you would have one area where you could
have a policy document where you all
work on it together
instead of having several versions of it
being emailed back and forth
which can take some time and a lot of
resources to collate
and agree um before passing any
decisions
for staff who have laptops and mobiles
they will be able to access teams on
different devices in real time
so somebody working on a laptop may have
to go off-site
they could then seamlessly continue the
conversation on teams via a mobile
phone successfulness
of teams is dependent on user training
and engagement
and people embracing and adopting new
ways of working
can we go to slide six please
okay i just have a brief overview of the
other products that that come along
there are lots of products on there and
i don't want to go into too much detail
for you
um but these are some of the ones i
think would be useful for the council
um you will have access to the latest
office products such as word excel
powerpoint
not having to buy further licenses to
keep up to date
um however you know we can have problems
with compatibility issues because of
that if some of the major business
applications don't keep up to date
some of the other useful products we've
got is planner um it's a card based
task management tool an alternative will
be trello
and provides a sort of kanban view for
those that may
are involved in idea or project work um
yama yama is a corporate social media
type of
platform sort of like facebook for the
workplace
forms and forms can be used to produce
surveys
um sharepoint sharepoint is a document
management area
and you can have intranets and websites
on there which quite
easily could be created um you can
access files remotely
and for example you could have the
policy documents on there
and be able to access them from your
ipad's mobile
phone etc microsoft bookings looks quite
interesting it's potential that you
could
schedule appointments maybe something
the contact centers could use to offer
appointments taxi licensing appointments
mot bookings those sort of things um and
then the power apps
which which could be used to automate
tasks and it could be used by the
developers
potentially um can we go to cli
slide seven now please joe thank you
thank you okay um along with the
licenses that we will purchase
um there will be some security and
tools which will help it to manage
manage the data and and the devices so
it comes with intune which is a mobile
device manager
um this will enable ict to manage
mobiles tablets and ipads
and laptops far more effectively and
securely for example it will reduce the
need
for you to bring your ipads in just to
get an update on an application
installed
and also provide some sort of
conditional access where we can restrict
what devices can access what
data so in the in the future there's
potential to use this for bring your own
devices
if that's something we wish to do
um it will also allow ict to
to regain some control over the cloud
and bring back visibility and management
of our data
we could stop people using free apps
such as whatsapp.box
g suite um in which we have minimal
control over what data is being stored
on there or who has access
can we go to slide eight please joe
okay next steps microsoft 365
implementation will take a lot of
resource to implement
there's a lot of background work which
will need to go on to prepare the
technical environment
it will be some time before you see the
improvement improvements such as teams
and sharepoint being implemented
for example we'll be commencing data
impact assessments with dpos
there's a lot of governance around
policy and security controls to ensure
data isn't lost
um a lot of housekeeping tasks that we
need to do and which will come out of a
readiness assessment
um we need to set up the single sign-on
with the azure active directory
implementing tune mobile device manager
so that we can make sure that your
devices that are accessing the data are
corporate devices and it's secured
um we'd then have to migrate the
mailboxes and the calendars to the cloud
it will only be then where we'll be in a
position to sort of
um promote teams and there'll be a lot
of project work involved to engage
yourselves and staff and getting
champions on board to train and adopt
new ways of working
and to adopt the new technologies and as
you can see there's a huge amount of
work and visuals required to roll out
the different elements of microsoft
office even before you see the notable
changes
okay if we could go to the last
thank you um i've tried to keep it
simple and but i know i've covered a lot
of information very quickly
and so please feel free to comment and
ask questions
uh thanks nikki i haven't got anybody
here on my
page of you uh
no chair no one seems to be asking
questions yes councillor whitehead
counseling exactly yeah thank you thank
you um
yeah that was a good presentation nikki
um it is a massive task um and i've been
through it and i think uh other people
on this
call has been through it as well and um
it's much needed though
you know we we cannot um move forward in
the next decade
without something like this um
you'll be interested to see what the
plan would be and and obviously the one
thing that you didn't quite touch on and
it's unknown at the moment is the cost
of implementation
not just the ongoing cost of of of this
service but
it's it's almost like if it's not this
um
then it's got to be something else um
and my general feeling is my
microsoft teams does wrap everything up
in a nice
package for us as a council
even though it's not something that i
personally use um it does feel like it's
a
it's a good one to to to consider
thank you anybody else any other
questions
um can you give us thanks oh counselor
sorry i'll come in later yeah my
question basically
if and when we decide to go ahead with
365
is the logistics of actually putting the
trade in
position because when a lot of people
are there that's going to need a lot to
trade
on a lot of issues within 365. have we
got any
uh sort of indication as to the the
the run out time and the cost of that
operation
um i think what we've got to do is we've
got to take it slowly and we've got to
do small bits at a time
so that people can embrace those changes
there is a lot of online information
that we can use microsoft have been
doing this for a long time and they do
provide a lot of information to help us
even whether it's a regard regarding
the project of how to engage people in
you know to use these tools to embrace
them
and to um effectively you know start
using them because if we just throw them
out there you're going to not use it
you know you'll go back to your emails
and you'll go back to how you're working
you work you've worked for years and so
it's there's a lot of project work
to do that um i think we're not really
at that stage where we could say how
long
it's going to take or how much it will
cost or how much resource it will cost
for that
i think if we concentrate on the
technical side of it first and
and we'll have a better understanding of
how we will use in the council
we won't roll everything out at once and
what we
we also need to do a piece of work
further on is is engaging
the council members more including the
staff and the management of staff
to say what is it you need and what is
going to make
improve your service technologically
to make you more agile or make you more
efficient and a lot of these things that
we've got with teams
and office 365 will improve those
um different sections and we've got to
do some work on that what
what we do want to do with office 365
it's not something we can just
throw out there um so
regards to we for northeast and bolsev
we are starting
on with we will get some consultancy
involved and we're hoping that we'll get
some funding to help with that
and so we can get the environment set up
and then
we will put in place what other projects
needs
need to um focus on after that to get it
out to yourselves and to make sure
you're trained
trained up and i know martin derbyshire
may be involved in you know training
yourselves up etc so that's that's
something which we will we will be
considering as we go along
yeah just a question question from me
nikki first of all
um any idea on time scale you know when
you'll have the
costs worked out by and also when you
reckon
implementation might be when we might we
actually have it on you know online
um i think there's a there's a lot of
background stuff
as i've said that where you won't
actually see
any benefit so there'll be a lot going
on that you won't
actually see the benefit for i can't
give you a specific
time scale at this moment in time but i
will update you
as we go along regards to costs i did
give indicative costs on the licensing
side of things
um in the november um
november uh meeting um which won't have
changed massively
but that's regarding the news cost and
and i can provide that and an organ
i can send out the screen that has those
on
uh that's something i think we're going
to work on and incorporate into the
budget so
i think karen sent
sent something through before about uh
we will have to do reports on
on what budget isn't required yeah thank
you
uh david
you muted david yeah
i've just done music thank you very much
nicholas a very useful report
um i just would like to report on
my experience as a town councillor with
teams and sharepoint and also my my
work experience with sharepoint i would
say i've been a sharepoint user
for 10 years and when we implemented it
we found it quite difficult
and but it it has been it was adopted
very widely in our company
and and it's been successfully adopted
it does need a lot of configuration i'm
sure you'll be doing that
um and it is quite diff it is quite
difficult to configure
configure well so i um
i'm sure i'm sure you'll be able to
manage that the uh
teams uh when we when we implemented
this in uh
matlock town council and we did that
over the last year
i was really impressed by how quickly
people
adopt adapted to it and adopted this
particularly teams
and so i certainly go along with your
enthusiasm for teams
that was that was mirrored by our office
staff who
and we've got uh five office staff and
various outside workers all of whom are
using teams
and they're using it very successfully
in the way that you suggest it
it would be used so yes i think that's a
it's a great product
um for for collaborative working and
they
they also adopted sharepoint uh and the
counselors council's adopted sharepoint
far faster than we did as a company ten
years ago it's probably improved but
also people's it experience which has
improved as well so i wish you well i
think it's i think it's a really good
thing to do
yeah thanks david any other questions
yes councillor white thank you
councillor white said i don't know why
they're not coming up on my screen alan
anyway
as long as you're keeping tabs on it
absolutely
thank you um nikki it might be wise to
to have a like a top level
critical path like over the next few
years of what it could look like
um and then maybe some milestones in
there what decisions
you're going to need to progress maybe
things that you can share you know
whether it's this committee or
or the councils um
so yeah i think that would be useful uh
what was the other thing
or something else i forgot it there i
think that was it
thank you no problem thank you
okay thank you anybody else
no other questions joe okay thank you
well thanks very much nikki
we can see that you've got a lot of work
ahead for you in the
next few months and years but a very
good presentation and much appreciated
okay we'll move on to item six which is
urgent business have we got anything
ellen
uh not that i'm a word officer okay
the final item is the date of the next
meeting which i believe
is february 8th that's correct yes
at 2 o'clock that's it yeah okie doke
okay well thanks very much for everybody
for attending
and we'll now close down i think
bye everybody
you